thank you
good evening everyone
welcome to this meeting of the
mid-suffolk district council I am
councilor James cast and the chairman
and I'll be chairing this meeting today
may I first remind you all of some
domestic Arrangements toilets are
situated outside the meeting room
opposite the stairs cold water is also
available in the breakout area outside
the meeting room if the fire alarm
should sound please leave the meeting
room by following the fire exit signs
and meet on the Ipswich Town Football
Club training pitch do not re-enter the
building until you are told it is safe
to do so please switch off all mobile
phones and laptops all turn them to
silent
thank you
I would like to remind everyone present
that this meeting will be broadcast live
to the internet and will be capable of
repeated viewing the whole of this
meeting will be filmed except where
there are confidential or exempt items
if you make a representation to this
meeting you are deemed by the council to
have consented to beam filmed by
entering this meeting you are also
consenting to being filmed by the
council and to the possible use of those
images and sound recordings for
webcasting and or training purposes the
council mem the council members of the
public
and the Press May record film photograph
or broadcast this meeting where the
public and the Press are not lawfully
excluded so I'll move to the agenda
thank you very much
um first item on the agenda is apologies
for absence
thank you very much and Declarations of
Interest by councilors
see no hands so I'd say none
item three to confirm the minutes of the
meeting held on the 23rd of February
2023 for accuracy only does anybody have
any issues with the accuracy of the
meeting with councilor Mansell
uh thank you I did send a message to the
governance team because it said that
there was a unanimous vote to extend the
meeting and I didn't vote for the
extending a meeting so it can't have
been a unanimous vote there was no vote
nobody asked if I voted against it was
just hands up and I obviously got missed
they obviously thought my hand was up
and it wasn't
it was a majority vote but not unanimous
votes okay so we'll we'll change that
word into the majority I also passed on
and I believe that's been actioned
sorry there was a typo that I also put
in the email okay and yeah thank you
very much
any other issues
okay could I have a proposer for the
minutes please
councilor Richardson and a seconder
councilor Whitehead
right so we'll do this as usual
um of a show of hands all in favor of
the minutes
with the amendments
and that is the majority thank you
so that's carried and so um
I'll go on to Chairman's announcements
item four
um please um
my papers for noting
um
in this um month I had my um Chairman's
meal and thank you for everyone that
attended it was a fantastic night at
watishan base
we raised um two and a half thousand
pounds for stowmarket ASD Saturday clubs
which um was is the last fundraising
opportunity of my term so um thank you
very much I don't have an absolute
I don't have an absolute grand total yet
but um that will all be revealed we we
went and announced that until May after
the election
so um there's still time to donate if
anybody um
comes into any money
so
it wouldn't be right to um
not just say a few words at this point
this being the final meeting of this
term
um I've I've been very proud to be the
chairman for this um Municipal year
um it's it's been a really wonderful
experience and I just wanted to um say
thank you to all members
for every everything you've put into
this I know some of you will not be um
with us in the next term I myself may
not be here so um I'd just like to say
those standing down and those that
um may may not be um elected
thank you so much for what you've done
and I want to wish everyone the best
luck for this election that's coming up
um
[Applause]
I'd also like to thank the leaders um
the leader of the council councilor
Morley
and um the leader of the leaders of the
opposition councilor Mellon and
councilor field for their input and
they've helped me through this role and
this council's done some amazing
business we've done some fantastic
things
um I felt the meetings have always been
very high value people have put so much
into it and um it's it's sad that we
won't be we won't have all the same
faces next term and some of the people
in this room are some of the finest
people I've ever met in my life I just
wanted to say that you you do so much
for your
um areas so much for this cancer Council
so thank you very much but I'll let I'll
get on with the meeting now thank you
so um okay so the next item is item five
leaders announcements and I'd like to
invite councilor Morley to present her
update
chair
I was delighted to attend the opening
earlier this month of the new police and
fire station of Needham Road Stone
Market
suffolk's Emergency Services have
recognized the excellent value for money
and benefits that collaborative working
provides for our residents and
communities and this is the latest
example of that
mid-suffolk District Council agreed a
431 thousand pounds worth contribution
to the project through the community
infrastructure Levy
and this new station will provide
excellent facilities for emergency
workers
the building also has a range of green
credentials including photovoltaic
panels and air source heat pump system
and 14 electric vehicle charging points
and our council is really proud to
support this
the transformation of the former need a
market middle school has now been
completed and we have received the keys
to all 41 new affordable homes
this development delivered by
mid-suffolk District Council and
supported by funding of 1.42 million
from homes England through the
affordable homes program is a great
investment in the town and a boost for
the community
it has provided more good quality
housing in our district
a mix of two and three bedroom
properties which were used as affordable
rent social rent and shared ownership
homes
the provision of a range of housing
options is vital for the sustainability
of our communities
in the form of Victorian School building
has also been converted into a new
library for the community
and finally many congratulations to
everyone involved in ensuring that
mid-suffolk is once again an ieasy
award-winning Council alongside baber
District
the awards are an annual opportunity to
celebrate and share the most Innovative
practice in transforming local public
services
and this year we were in the running for
two categories
we won silver in the green Public
Services award category for our tree
canopy survey and tree planting
initiative
the pioneering project which allows us
to understand and measure our existing
tree coverage and to use it to support
and improve biodiversity in our
districts
we also won bronze in the asset
management and regeneration award
category for Gateway 14. which as we
know is set to bring thousands of jobs
to the area
well done to everyone involved in
delivering these projects as a council
we can be extremely proud of these all
of these achievements
and finally I'd like to say a big thank
you to all of our district councilors
for the last four years
we've achieved a heck of a lot together
and I thank you all for your energy and
enthusiasm and not to mention your
endurance
thank you all and I've been really proud
to be leader of this Council for the
last four years thank you
[Applause]
thank you very much thank you very much
are there any questions for Clarity on
the leaders announcements
no thank you so we'll move on to item
six on the agenda to receive
notifications of petitions in accordance
with the council's procedure rules
thank you chair non-received
questions by the public in accordance
with the council procedure rules
none received questions by counselors in
accordance with the council procedure
rules none received thank you very much
so we move on to item 9
mc2242 the overview and scrutiny
committee report I'd like to invite
councilor wellum to introduce his report
councilor wellum
thank you chair
I'm pleased to present this report the
last for the present Municipal year
in addition to the topics listed in my
report overview and scrutiny met this
morning to consider an information
bulletin from the director of operations
this was a review of the public realm
service following the operations within
labor District being brought in-house
in terms of delivery of the service in
mid-suffolk there have been few changes
are just changes in the way no hardly
any changes in the way that the service
has been delivered however significant
improvements to the delivery in favor
were found to be necessary and have been
implemented
the the advantages of having a
management team covering both districts
are clear and a firm base is being
established from which further
improvements will be possible
details of the scrutiny reviews
undertaken in January and February are
set out in my report
calling of the cabinet decision in
November 2022 in respect of the proposal
for an Exemplar housing scheme in
elmsworld was debated and
recommendations made to cabinet
recommendations for further
investigatory work and local
consultation
and chair may I thank all the members of
the Overfield security committee and the
staff for their work during last year
thank you very much
thank you Council well are there any
questions counselor Passmore
oh there you go right um thank you very
much just a quick one if I made Keith I
see in the report that you talk about
the tourism strategy review and it makes
it makes a recommendation that the um
Council notes the comments was there a
concern in the committee for those of us
who have been on that working group
including Penny and myself that there
was a risk that that all those Endeavors
would not be taken note of because
clearly a lot of the time has gone into
it it's a very important stretch he's
got a real potential to get the economy
motoring here in mid-suffer I just
wondered if there was any concern
expressed at the scrutiny committee
about this uh well home strategy thank
you
Council of William
thank you chair
um thank you Mr councilor Passmore no
there weren't any any real objections at
all to the strategy
um comments were made that we need to
see an action plan a delivery plan
because the strategy is of no no worth
without some actions coming out of it
and there were one or two other
suggestions for further investigation
there were one or two areas which didn't
appear to be have been included in the
strategy which could have been included
for instance I think industrial Heritage
was one of them because agricultural
Heritage another
so they were just suggestions for
including with well investigating and
including in the strategy well that was
all thank you
thank you councilor even
thank you chair and thank you councilor
wellum um I just wondered with regards
to the discussion on pre-app
um whether there was any discussion
around making the pre-app discussions
public or at the very least um advising
Parish councils of of what
um elements had been discussed within
the pre-app thank you
councilor Willem
thank you thank you councilor eberne
there was mention of making the pre-app
discussions public
but in particular to share the advice or
to be part of the the formation of the
advice
that Ward members should be part of that
but there there was not any sort of
agreement that that was an essential
part but it is something which we know
that some developers and their agents
take advantage of we know that they do
contact Ward members and so they did
seem to be good reasons for that but as
far as an overall an overall rule that
that would be part of the pre-app that
was not agreed
thank you very much councilor Mallon
just ask um councilor Wellen um going
back to the pre-app
clearly there's a sort of low level of
satisfaction with the advice that people
receive and clearly this is something
that people pay for was the committee
able to sort of uh tease out what the
reasons are why people are dissatisfied
with the level of advice they're getting
thank you
uh thank you councilor Merlin uh
the the data collected for the
satisfaction survey showed fluctuation
in the level of satisfaction with
various aspects of advice for instance
at any particular area of advice it may
go up or down so uh there are there are
occasions where one aspect of the
service was particularly bad for one
year but not necessarily for the next so
we're definitely going up and down
um
but um
uh yeah I mean there was there was some
expression of of
a desire for that level to be increased
improved and so that's the reason why I
keep a a kpi was set for
um a general satisfaction level
um possibly not too challenging uh a kpi
but our concerns as a committee were
that because there's been such a lot of
fluctuation and the period included
covert and just postcoded that we didn't
we didn't really uh feel that it had to
be achievable it wasn't it wasn't
sensible to make it particularly High a
high level so I think
uh one one of the things I mean we had
we had Witnesses from three Witnesses
who were agents or developers or
architects
and it seemed from the discussion that
one thing which which influenced the
satisfaction with the advice was whether
or not there was a planning permission
at the end of it
thank you very much I can't see any
further questions so um we'll move on to
the next item thank you
so um the next item is item 10
mc2243 Community infrastructure Levy
cell the sil expenditure framework fifth
review March 2023 and for this item I'd
like to invite councilor Byrne to
introduce and to move the
recommendations councilor Byrne
thank you chairman
the select expenditure framework and
communication strategy were originally
agreed and adopted by both councils in
March 20
t
it has been reviewed on a yearly basis
ever since through the work of a joint
panel
and has also been considered by joint
overview and scrutiny
it was agreed in July 2022 that it would
be reviewed for a fifth time by The
Joint member panel to ensure that it
keeps Pace with changing infrastructure
demands and delivery
this report and the recommended changes
are the outcome of that work
the fifth review took place in December
2022 and January 2023
the members of The Joint member panel
are listed in paragraph 1.3 of the
report and I thank them for their
involvement
uh sadly I was Ill over that those two
months in fact and so I was unable to
attend this panel
um and forgive me therefore if I'm not
as unfair with its findings and its
recommendations as I might otherwise be
the key changes to both documents are
listed in full in paragraph 4.5 in the
report
firstly the cell expenditure framework
as you will see key changes are around
libraries
a clawback facility and a reduction in
the period for quotations to be held
you will also see the joint member panel
confirmed our position regarding
feasibility studies for district heating
schemes and proposals from businesses
for business purposes
the new hundred thousand pound limit is
endorsed as is the use of ring fence
monies first
you will remember the stance taken in
the fourth review which prevented the
use of District sill for Highway
measures
however we are now recommending
including Highway measures those which
form part of a walking and cycling
project for an LC whip scheme
this is this is in addition to other
Highway measures any other Highway
measures that might be delivered by
developments through section 106 and or
under Section 278 of the highways Act
by continuing with this opportunity for
funding We Believe still will be a key
component in delivery of LC work schemes
you will also see we're asking that we
continue the proactive approaches for
expenditure of District seal and
spending of neighborhood still to
encourage the delivery of infrastructure
projects to support growth
and that we keep the still expenditure
framework under review
we suggest another review which will be
the sixth should occur whilst bid round
12 is underway in October 23 2023 so
there's any revision sort of adopted
before bidrone 13 in May 2024
and finally we agree The Joint member
panel will remain to inform the sixth
review
chairman moving on to Sil expenditure
framework communication strategy
there is a small change proposed to the
way we consult on sale bids consultation
will continue in the agreed way with the
same parties and for the same 14-day
period but Sylvan no longer need to be
valid for consultation to occur
we will also be looking to allow
extensions of time when requested to do
so
finally we will continue with three
briefings each year for members and
parishes building on the well-attended
and well-received briefings held in
December 2022.
so I am asking Council to agree the
changes under the recommendations in
Section 3 of the report
and they are at 3.4 the mid-suffolk
council approved the recommendation
approve the amendments to the Civil
expenditure framework March 2023 arising
from the fifth review appendix a in your
papers and the cell expenditure
framework communication strategy of
March 2023 which is appendix B in your
papers
at 3.5 the mid-suffolk council agrees
that the Civil expenditure framework and
the silk expenditure framework
communication strategy be reviewed again
whilst mid round 12 is being considered
in October 2023 so that any amended
scheme can be in place before bedrum 13
occurs in May 2024
and at 3.6 that mid-suffolk agrees that
the joint member panel be retained to
inform the sixth review
uh so chairman I'm proposing these
recommendations and that the production
of the yearly cell calendar for
2023-24 is agreed by delegated powers
and I look Prosecco to thank you
thank you councilor Mansell
uh I'm happy
thank you very much and we'll now move
to questions we have the um the
portfolio holder here um but also we
have Christine Thurlow who's the
professional lead for key sites and
infrastructure so are there any
questions
counselor eburn
thank you chair um thank you councilor
Byrne for that report and thank you to
the officers for their their work and
the working group on this
um can I just ask with regards to using
seal for professional fees
um such as Architects fees and um
planning
um fees for planning permissions
um because it seems that those still
aren't included and that's often quite a
big stumbling block block in terms of
getting projects moving forward and um I
do understand that apparently
neighborhood still can be used but not
mid-sufficillin I just would like to
know
um more about that if there was a
discussion around that when this was
being reviewed about whether
um the metaphoric seal can be used for
professional fees and what the reasons
were for not including it thank you
councilor burn
thank you councilor even well as I said
unfortunately I wasn't present at those
meetings so the the
small print or the small talk very uh I
don't know I will ask um uh professional
lead for keysights and infrastructure to
answer that question for me thank you
thank you
um early doors at the start of when we
set out the silly expenditure framework
we decided on some key principal issues
and one of the things that we had to
take into account uh is that District
cell and should be used for
infrastructure provision only so in
doing so that did knock out uh
professional fees and Architects fees
but what we do is we work with other
funders in order to secure the payment
of those elements as part of projects so
that the project can ultimately be
landed and one of the things we can do
is to look to Neighborhood sale for that
or we can look to other funders so we we
do scan far and wide too
ensure that we take that on board
thank you councilor Fleming
thank you um I just had a question about
the use
of silver traffic calming which has not
been brought into the current cell
expenditure framework this time I think
the reason
um stated is that there's an assumption
that highways will pay for this but I
think that fails to recognize the subtle
aspect of Highways funding that actually
highways won't play for a lot of traffic
calming measures that parishes want and
these often arise from the accumulation
of developments over time and the need
to make villages and Roads that are go
through them safe for pedestrians and
cyclists to use and feel confident to
use and I feel that I would like to ask
that the next time the sill is reviewed
that traffic calming measures in
particular those that highways does not
normally fund be part of that you again
I feel I've had several parishes that
hoped cell could be used for traffic
farming and
the measure the problems arise directly
from development
and what we need is a response to to
growth and development that reflects
actually what people want and is largely
developer
um
it originates from developers and
development and I feel that there should
be some way of recouping those costs
um would you like to comment
um the professional lead for key sites
and infrastructure
please
thank you
members will
plan growth projects come forward there
are formal consultations that take place
as part of a planning application and
one of those formal consultations
involves the highway Authority and they
do look at the uh the impact on road
safety terms of individual proposals but
they also consider cumulative impact and
I think that was the first reason why
last year when this was looked up
members felt that those considerations
were taken on board and therefore use of
of District still might be something
over and above that was necessary
because those financial contributions by
Developers
should be aimed towards Highway matters
as you'll see from your report this time
in the fifth review members reconsidered
that matter and stood by that decision
subject to the
inclusion of highway traffic calming
measures as part of an LC whip case
because it would make no sense to put in
a walking and cycling facility if you
didn't have all of the elements
necessary to make that safe
thank you
any further questions Council Byrne
well thank you Joe it's not a question
it's um
an observation that this is a very
important issue I'll um I'll take it
into debate now because I couldn't see
any further questions and you can you
can start the debate then thank you can
I start back now yes please along these
lines in um jolly good save me sitting
down and standing up again
um
I
it is a very sensitive subject and this
is community infrastructure Levy the the
Clue's in the name and it's a community
wish
I think by many many communities that
I've come across the the traffic calming
through their Villages is a very
important issue and I will therefore put
whatever weight I can behind a councilor
Fleming's suggestion that it be included
again in the agenda for the next um uh
for the next review in October
thank you
thank you very much councilor Passmore
thank you very much chairman
um yes I'd like to support that I do
think looking at some of these issues
regarding the cumulative effect of extra
development never knows he got more than
enough of that in mid-suffolk overall
wherever you go and of course the I
suppose the attrition if you like for
one of the better word when you get
fairly large developments in some of our
even some of our smaller Villages and
Market towns does it add up and
sometimes I can say that at the planning
committee meetings that I sit on we are
we do occasionally have some concerns
about the information provided by
highways we have to take what's given
and I think it's very difficult for
highways to consider what are the longer
term impacts anyway
um and therefore I would welcome the
opportunity to look at that and of
course there are other issues you could
put into this
some of them you could regard as having
improvements for environmental
improvements the quality of living and
there are many many other things that go
into it so it's never quite as black and
white perhaps as people consider so if
that could be looked at
um I think that's really really
important and I know this is in a
different District but you probably are
all aware of um was it Benton Street in
Hadley where in the middle of a
Conservation Area traffic calming
however you do it's almost impossible
but we do need to look after our built
Heritage as well and therefore if
they're a way to weave that in I think
um in the longer term that would be
helpful because in a street like that
and there are others in mid-suffolk
anyway then extra traffic for whatever
else it is is very difficult for a
planning authority to know what it will
be in the future and if there are
improvements then um why wouldn't we at
least have a look at it even if it was
kept at a certain level so I would
certainly support
um David and Jessica's comments on that
thank you
thank you councilor Passmore counselor
eburn and then councilor field
um thank you very much chair um I think
one of the the key things that we need
to do is ensure that the sill that we
collect at mid-suffolk is spent
um and is spent particularly in those
areas that have had a lot of development
Parish councils look at the the numbers
the millions
um of cell that is um sat in with
suffolks um bank accounts and want to
know where that's being spent and what
it's doing for their communities a lot
of the communities I'm involved with are
very proactive in using neighborhood
still and getting their own projects
done off the ground but they really
really really need support from The
District in order to do those wider
projects that will
um where there's been a lot of
development to improve those areas and
just seeing the money kind of Stack Up
is not um it's not helpful and I think
they do need to see that money being
spent and be also be consulted and
involved in how that that um
councilwide fund fund is spent but I do
like I say appreciate the work that goes
on with this but we do need to ensure
that those communities where they've had
a lot of development do see the
mid-suffolk element of the sale fund
spent in their areas while they are
working really hard all these volunteers
working really hard to actually use the
seal money themselves on their own
neighborhood and Community projects
thank you
thank you councilor even councilor field
thank you I was just going to support
the views I think on traffic calming
that is an import
ant of communities basically they're
resistant to resistance to development
or that's what it provokes and as we all
know highways are very
restricted in their budgets and always
reluctant to to do anything even
approaching the
desires of the local community
also support Council England's views on
ability of our funding the points I
really wanted to make myself perhaps so
that um
I find that it certainly in my world in
my area the only real large cell
expenditures that I've gone through are
those for educational purposes
the enhancement of the two primary
schools
exceeds by a very large amount they
spend on any other objects
and in fact if I look at the parish
councils in the area
they seem to have a strong tendency to
rely on funding from particularly from
Suez which is easy to access it's still
restricted to about fifty thousand
pounds so it's quite a small sum in
modern terms
understand
even something like a children's
playground now but it can be anything
from 100 to 200 000 pounds and we tend
to restrict our funding at a low level
we do that to to get a combination of
funding but of course that makes quite
an administrative problem for what are
often small Parish councils run by
volunteers who don't wish to spend their
entire life filling up paperwork and
making bids to various funding bodies so
I think over in support of all the
Amendments that are going through here I
would recommend that we're in the future
we look really at the complexity of our
processes about the the need to gain
funding from a series of sources for
each project might be one project could
fund each Source you'd get the
get them so I think this is an area that
we do need to look at carefully and we
need to look at with perhaps a more open
mind than we have in the past um we've
tended to stick to what we set out to do
initially and not modify it in any
significant way thank you
thank you councilor field councilor
Mansell
thank you chair I I will be supporting
the recommendations
um and I actually think that much of the
discussion so far points to a huge hole
um in Suffolk County Council highways
comments on planning applications
because all of those things that you've
just said should be brought up when we
consult our highways colleagues in the
county and they should be saying things
about road safety and cumulative impact
of all the developments in some of our
communities they are the experts we're
not
um so I think I agree that that there
are big holes and there are an awful lot
of things that our communities want but
when highways come to consult on our the
planning applications in our Villages
they say nothing about those those
issues and I think that is a missed
opportunity it's a missed opportunity
because if there are
um large road safety measures that
should be taken in order to facilitate
development then the county ought to be
saying so so that we can then get the
developer to help fund it
um you know there are projects and I'm
sure you can all think of projects that
are being carried out by developers that
seem to be
um the minimum the bare minimum that is
expected of them and fair enough
Suffolk County highways don't have a lot
of funds but the developers have plenty
of funds and if Suffolk County Highway
said oh can we have this you know
um all singing all dancing bit of uh
cycle or pedestrian or road safety
infrastructure the developers would
cough up they've got the money and yet
highways don't ask for it so I think I I
I totally agree that we need an awful
lot of traffic issues dealt with in our
district
um but I really think that that our
highways comments ought to be backing us
um and yes um uh if you can waggle your
traffic calming scheme into uh a project
for active travel brilliant you cannot
you can get some cell money we shouldn't
have to be going through those hoop
holes but I think we are we should be
asking highways to be a bit more
critical of of the impact of of traffic
uh when all these new developments get
built
um so yes I'm quite happy that it is
looked at next time
um I would like to say that I welcome
the fact that we can now use cell money
for active travel projects because that
I think was an Omission earlier on and I
completely agree with councilor eberne
in that we need to get this money spent
spent in a timely manner we have all
these developments in our communities
and they say that all of these bits of
infrastructure are a necessity for that
development to go ahead and yet we have
the development going ahead being um you
know well over 60 occupied and or even
100 occupied and we still don't have
that infrastructure a lot of the
projects that um are necessary are such
big projects they need somebody to
project manage them I mean we we can't
expect our our cell team here they do
they do a great job in what they do do
but they're not there to to spearhead
every project that is needed and and
cancel field said that these volunteers
who run the permission
three minutes but you're just talking so
passionately would you like to just have
a feeling that you know we can't expect
volunteers for Parish councils to
spearhead enormous infrastructure
projects I don't know what the answer is
but yes it is something that we we
probably look at thank you thank you and
sorry to stop you but um councilor
wellum
thank you chair and thank you to
councilman Mansell I fully support what
she's saying but I can't do it as
passionately as she can
um and that you know that's that's good
to hear but it does point us towards the
need for an in-house Highway specialist
somebody who can challenge what the what
the county is saying and come up with
the sorts of ideas in a way that
councilman cell was was saying uh so I
think that is that is a need that's a
gap really in the service that we could
provide to our planning officers and to
our committees but
the issue of funding Road Safety imagine
I support consideration being given to
funding these measures from cell
but there is a note of caution and that
is that for instance Parish Council have
been funding such measures in the past
and they've found there's no maintenance
and there's no replacement and the
measures are no longer effective
examples are anti-skid surfacing that's
put down and it's never replaced 30 mile
per hour roundels put down never
replaced and entry treatments that are
never kept up so there needs to be a way
of securing ongoing maintenance costs
not just providing the measures thank
you
thank you thank you very much councilor
Pratt
um yeah I just wanted to say that
generally on the whole um I think you
know it's it's quite positive review and
might be supporting the measures in the
framework that have been suggested I
represent a very uh rural award
um and um
at least one I think two villagers
actually are in a very proactive being
very proactive in um trying to plan for
traffic calming measures themselves I
think that you know using uh cell to to
help with traffic funding measures would
be generally very welcomed by our
parishes there's also quite a lot of
proactive work going into
um
local uh LC uh whip infrastructure so
I'm really really pleased to see a
continuation of funding for in support
of our LC rep projects as well
thank you
thank you councilor councilor Carter
I reached it eventually right thank you
um I went to the second Vanessa V Nestle
for our seal gets spent an entirely
measure and also the importance of
traffic calming measures
I would say regards to be spending the
sale regards improvements to active
travel marvelous I would encourage
creative usage of said active travel
well these funds can not only be used to
improve on footpaths but measures to put
in place to prevent or discourage
pavement parking whitening footpaths
improve on biodiversity the diversity
plunking some trees improve on access to
schools and Implement school drop-offs
and trains to school either walking or
cycling improving on children's health
and changing the mindset of parents and
drivers where this can be spent where
it's going to help with people
over better
thank you
thank you councilman Matheson
thank you chair yeah I I agree with all
the things that have been said about
highways however I think the other thing
that that at the planning committee and
at the parish councils we keep hearing
about infrastructure or where's the
infrastructure and the other thing is
the health infrastructure now I know
somewhere in the middle of the um bullet
points at the power 4.6
um to continue with the current
proactive approach
um etc etc
um health and waste so
I think what the public
doesn't see is that Health
infrastructure actually coming forward
and appearing now we all know that it's
difficult to recruit
GPS and so on but
the public expects to see something
happening and if we were to get
fortunate in recruiting more more
doctors then where would they be
actually sitting and you know I don't
see the proactive approach is actually
dragging forward applications from the
health authorities to actually spend
still money
um I'm sure someone will correct me and
say oh we've got an extra something like
our surgery somewhere but
um you know thousands and thousands of
houses have been built by this
what the permission of this district and
um you know the the health is not
keeping up so I think somehow we have to
politically
twist the arms a bit more and improve
our political liaison with the health
authorities to actually get stuff to
happen
thank you councilor Stringer oh would
you councilor Fleming would you like to
come back on something that's been said
there
if I might just really briefly I think
councilor mathison's raised a very um
important point but I just
problem is with the Health Service
itself they don't ask for enough and I
have actually raised this in in a
separate Arena
um they they look at it in a fairly
narrow way much as schools does on a
sort of per pupil formulaic way without
understanding that when you reach a
certain level of additional patience you
actually can't go on expanding that
particular Center you need to build a
new one so I think there's some
education and dialogue that's needed
with the Health Service whose job it is
to comment on planning applications and
that I think is located in ethics so I
think that's something we can all take
away outside of this meeting
thank you Council Stringer
thank you uh just want to make just a
couple comments I want to prolong the
debate or or any argument from it uh if
if we're dealing with planning
applications uh and there is uh traffic
calming needed there is an existing
route to make that happen and it should
be under a section 106 agreement it
should be a condition of that planning
application because if it is quote
needed because of that development
therefore it should be there it should
not it should not wait as it were for
the the sill framework to claw money
back and then if a parish would like to
spend it they can and that that's too
cumbersome for something that is safety
orientated to to be honest and Frank so
that so I'm quite comfortable with the
policy the way it is I think the issue
about being able to have other
infrastructure for walking and cycling
allows that bit of wiggle room as it
were uh to to for parishes to be
creative if if the ball is being dropped
and I think that's the Crux of it I
think we have to get smarter and sharper
about what we prove and how we approve
planning applications uh for instance uh
most of my life in another chamber that
also shares this chamber an awful lot of
that time is spent trying to mop up the
Carnage that happens after planning
approvals take place uh yesterday alone
in one Village that I serve there was a
lorry every minute for six hours sorry
that was on Friday long weekend
um there was there was a lorry every
single minute for six hours on one
development out of four
and there was no conditions for any
infrastructure that came from that 50
House Development so I think there is an
element of yes we can put it in the in
the seal framework but I think that's
rather almost shutting the door after
the horse's bothered I would also like I
make a slight plea when there are
consultations and we're working on uh
committees like this to bring about
changes to documents if we've got ideas
and things we want to push can we push
those that are on there on our behalf
rather than wait till we've literally
got the document in the meeting when
it's actually a bit late to amend things
but anyway I'll be agreeing with the
document I think and I thank everyone
that had input into it thank you
thank you very much now I'm councilor
burn would you like to add anything
before we take this to the boat
stringers
remarks which I
wholeheartedly support
um
I'd just say one thing though that in
many villages
it's not so much the
nearby the development of large size
that has caused the problems it's been a
creeping problem that has developed over
a period of time but you can't point a
finger at any one development and
therefore you can't immediately or you
couldn't have proactively solved that
problem by slapping a 106 condition on
on any particular development that's why
it's necessary for uh if you like almost
retrospective methods of
dealing with that particular problem but
uh
would you would you like me to sum up
if you if you'd care to your councilman
well uh it's just I think it's been a
very very useful debate and I'm I'm sure
that uh our professional lead for the
keysights and infrastructure will have
taken a lot away from it and I hope so
anyway because
um it's a very difficult job for
Christine and her team and I do
recommend them very very highly indeed
for the way in which they do it uh
mean to say that we've got to make it
easy for her
I think I think it is important that we
keep her on our toes because she's a
very very capable and her team members
too are very very capable and I do
commend them uh wholeheartedly for the
way in which they handle this it's not
an easy job it's a very complicated job
and certain certain aspects of it
do take a very long time that's
unfortunate but but it's it's inevitable
so
on that on that note I think we can draw
this item to a close chairman if you if
you would like to have we got a second
did we get a secondary
yeah oh yes councilman thank you very
much
what about that
but anyway jolly good I'll leave it
there then thank you very much everybody
thank you very much councilor burn and
thank you everyone that took part in
that that was a very useful um debate so
I'll now take that to um the vote I'll
ask the corporate manager governance and
Civic office to conduct that vote thank
you
[Music]
blue for cancers to cost their vote
thank you
Council Carter can I take your boat
yes yes
thank you
and councilor Brewster
um can I take your Vote or is it coming
through yeah
thank you
29 boats
thank you that's 29 votes for so that's
unanimous and that's carried thank you
I'll um move on to item 11 now
mc2244 draft joint local planning
enforcement plan 2023.
um this again and this again would be um
councilor Burns and I'd like to invite
him to introduce this item and to move
the recommendations thank you councilor
burn
finger chimney
okay the existing
local planning enforcement plan was
adopted in 2017.
and then December 2020 after considering
considering a report on the enforcement
service The Joint overview on scrutiny
committee instructed the chief planning
officer to establish a joint member
officer Tuscan finish group to review
and make recommendations on the GOP
having regard to best practice and other
examples of good practice
a process of service transformation in
planning enforcement has therefore been
in progress since early 2020
this has included the setting up of that
joint member working group consisting of
mid-suffolk councilors Guthrie Stringer
and myself and from baber my counterpart
councilor arthi and his colleagues
councilors Ward and Busby
the working group first met in May 2022
it has looked in detail at the issues
that members of the public have commonly
encountered when reporting suspected
breaches of planning control to the
council
it also discussed at length the language
used in the draft plan to make the new
wording as clear and straightforward as
reasonably possible for public
understanding of the process
during the course of its work the
working group reviewed other examples of
good practice in planning enforcement
policies at other councils including
Ashford Borough Council West
northamptonshire Council Red Bridge
Borough Council and Milton Keynes
Council
the group also considered what good
practice for baber and mid-suffolk
should look like
officers have also been process mapping
and efficiency review
using Vizio software
they have been working on the
development and introduction into use of
a suite of consistent actions and
templates using software called uniform
and bringing into day-to-day use by the
enforcement team the case management
software known as Enterprise which is
already used in the development
Management Service
the new joint local planning enforcement
plan comprises the plan itself
which is included as appendix a in the
report it is supplemented with a
prioritization strategy which is
appendix B and for clarity also included
is a simplified simplified investigation
workflow diagram as appendix C
plan document sets out an explanation of
the principles behind planning
enforcement activity
to explain more transparently how these
investigations are considered it
summarizes and explains the council's
approach to planning enforcement what is
and what is not a breach of planning
control and explains how suspected
breaches should be reported for
investigation
the policy our plan refers to the
prioritization strategy and process map
to explain how reports will be
investigated
the current 2017 policy filters reports
into three categories
high medium or low priority
and the new policy streamlines this into
two categories
where the breach is a planning matter
into high priority site visit within
three working days or standard priority
site visit within 10 working days
the policy also describes the tax test
of expediency which the council must
Undertake and what will happen if the
council does or does not decide to
proceed with formal action
the policy explains how the council will
communicate with members of the public
and other interested parties
as I've said in order to more
transparently explain how investigations
are considered the prioritization
strategy details the factors and
weighting that will be given to
different matters through the course of
Investigation
it explains the approach to scoring
suspected infringement by type harm and
impact that will guide decisions on
which cases will be investigated
the investigation workflow diagram is a
simplified process map showing the
pathways that the typical stages of an
investigation can take it has been
developed during the transformation of
the service and is now being used to
help manage the workflow of new cases
coming into the teeth
the workflow is generic and does not
provide the level of detail available to
service managers as it is felt that
publishing this could disadvantageous
were someone under investigation to
exploit the content to delay effective
scrutiny of the suspected breach
uh chairman I'm proposing the
recommendation set out in section 6 of
the report now section 6.1 asks you to
adopt the draft joint local planning
enforcement plan set out in appendix one
and publish it on the council's website
6.2 asks that the director of Planning
and Building control is asked to make
any necessary amendments in order to
finalize the policy
and as this is a new approach to
investigation management 6.3 recommends
that this is reviewed by a joint member
officer working group after 12 months to
ensure that it is effective efficient
and ensures that cases causing
unacceptable planning harm are
appropriate investigated appropriately
investigated uh I'd just like to point
out that in 6.1
the word policy is used instead of plan
so it's a joint local planning
enforcement plan not a joint local
enforcement
policy
right I should have mentioned that you
can see on page 211 of your of your
papers the key revisions to the policy
can be summarized as follows and and for
the benefit of those that haven't got uh
easy access to that document may I
please just just read out the key
revisions
um they are streamlining the document
using plain English where possible and
removing much of the technical language
so that it's much easier to follow
number two is providing a clear insight
into what planning enforcement is and
what it seeks to achieve
three provides a clearer picture to
those who rely on the service as to what
they can expect when they're involved in
either reporting or being asked to act
in response to a planning enforcement
letter
the next is providing an explanation as
to why in some circumstances the council
might decide that it is not expedient to
take formal action against a breach of
planning control
and next ensuring that the policy offers
the council the flexibility to exercise
its enforcement powers in the most
effective and appropriate way
last but one is affirming the importance
of keeping interested parties aware of
our progress in a timely manner and
finally ensuring the online reporting
system allows officers to collect an
acceptable level of information to Aid
the investigation from the start that is
my introduction James thank you
you very much councilor burn do I have a
second after that
councilor flatman
the second chair
and I'll um I'll now move to questions
we also have in the back row there um
Tom Barker director of for Planning and
Building control and Philip Isbell the
chief planning officer so um we'll um
we'll go to questions
councilor Fleming
thank you I'm not sure if my hand was up
first but
I'm happy to barge the queue my question
is um
about
conditions governing construction
activity how are these dealt with or
going to be dealt dealt with within the
new framework I'll give an example
100 homes are built in Village a
um
summer is a bit dry clouds of dust are
churned up the place looks like the
Sahara and I get loads of complaints
however after
numerous efforts
an enforcement officer goes out however
some rain had fallen in the night and he
saw nothing
um
and nothing really can be done that this
needs to be addressed and I think it's
really important for communities to feel
that the planning authorities behind
them when they have problems with
operators and developers and lorries and
all those things that are quite
transitory in nature how can we get some
confidence that these will be dealt with
this is the chief planning officer
through through you chairman um the
prioritization strategy describes what
we will do in relation both to um
breaches of pre-commencement conditions
and to conditions which affect uh harm
to General immunity so I think in
general terms the prioritization
strategy sets out that we will look into
the question of detail of individual
circumstances the workflow describes how
we expect dialogue with members to be uh
take to take place at various different
points through the process of
investigation and clearly there is a
point here that
officers do need to understand for
members what issues they are
experiencing in in addition to anything
that they meet they may be investigating
for themselves
clearly in discussing individual cases
in this situation where you're dealing
with a generic policy a generic plan
um it is difficult but we do understand
as officers that there are issues with
construction management and indeed it's
something that the director of Planning
and Building control and I've been
discussing how to approach that question
of conditions compliance because with so
many sites coming forward across the
district that question of giving
communities confidence in the way that
we manage these conditions is absolutely
essential
thank you very much councilman Norris
was your hand up
thank you councilor Norris thank you Mr
chairman uh just picking up on the
second from last bullet point on post
211 on the key revisions that came to
confirm redo affirming the importance of
keeping interested parties aware of our
progress in the timely manner
would it be possible to include within
the plan a provision for members to
receive a periodic update on open
Enforcement cases in their award
these are the sort of questions that
members frequently get asked I have
mentioned the possibility of a periodic
update previously to enforcement during
the last 18 months or so and I've been
told that it is being worked on but I
haven't seen any indication of it
materializing to date
and also women enforcement case is
closed could brief details of the
outcome be provided not just that is
being closed
thank you
councilor burn
I think it comes from the noise I I must
say with regard to your your second
point I I think I completely agree with
that I do find the reports we get on the
closing of Enforcement cases are
sometimes less than uh understandable so
we put it that way because the the
reason is I forget now the exact wording
um but it it is fairly cryptic and it
would be better to have a a sort of
range of interpretative
terms that those
General comments actually refer to
even if they're not spelled out we could
probably
um
check them by code or something like
that that doesn't matter but I agree
with you on that one so far as
notifying the uh the the all members of
the
cases going on in their ward in a timely
manner
my experience with that is that but but
then I am portfolio holder for planning
that I've always been kept in in
informed about about such things
um I think it's something that I I with
with the expertise of the chief planning
officer and the director for planning
for building control I'd be loath to add
any comments to that so could you
perhaps refer it to them please
the chief planning officer
thank you the
um workflow itself contains various
points at which
um the policy the plan would expect
um
counselors to receive updates
the question of the clarity of those
updates is something which from my point
of view is a matter of ongoing training
so that officers communicate effectively
with members and that this becomes a
two-way dialogue
a lot so that information is clear and
uh from from a personal point of view
there may sometimes be situations where
some of our reasoning around the
enforcement may be sensitive and we may
not wish to release it into
um General circulation so
there are points here which within the
workflow describe communication with all
members and they are an opportunity for
two-way dialogue about enforcement
investigations
um in both specific terms and in general
terms
as regards to the content of what is
said I'm afraid it is a perennial source
of dissatisfaction to me that the
language of enforcement is
somewhat
um well it's not a matter of plain
English frankly and it is a very legal
subject at times I think it's fair to
say this is something that the joint
member task companies group wrestled
with itself and I would hope that
officers do provide briefings which are
intelligible and as far as possible in
plain English and deal with the planning
breaches that members need to take back
to their communities so that they can be
explained with a greater Clarity than
your average lawyer might expect
thank you very much councilor Stringer
very quick Point uh actually just a
question and it sums up what you've been
going through I think uh it says under
the second to last bullet point that the
importance of keeping interested parties
aware uh can I just confirm the elected
board members are interested parties
and just to also make the plea that
that he was suggesting that if sensitive
information were given to councilors it
would then be in general circulation
just to remind officers that we we are
actually Bound by confidentiality and if
we were to breach that but there are you
know could be penalties thank you
Chief planning officer
I'm aware of that uh thank you chair and
from from my perspect that that is
understood although one I must obviously
be careful with any conversation uh that
one has regarding some of the more
um difficult technical details regarding
a breach or an alleged breach which one
may very well suspect but one cannot
actually prove because these are matters
that can end up in a criminal court
workflow does describe a number of
points through the process which quite
clearly show where what members are
expected to be updated and uh in the
first instance some of these will be
points which will be by my email so I'm
afraid the volume of email is going to
cancel is inevitably going to increase
but I would hope they provide a point of
contact and discussion with officers in
the enforcement team if there are any if
there's any absence of clarity about the
message or indeed the issues and our
assessment of them
um I think that's it from my perspective
thank you very much councilman Matheson
please
thank you chair
um yeah a couple of questions
um first one
probably to the director
um I seem to recall it a rumor rule
perhaps two years ago
um that that we were going to buy a
drone for to to assist with planning
enforcement and another planning
activities
um I don't think that ever happened
um why not
other question
did the working group actually consider
improving the
the reporting of enforcement in the
sense of providing some analysis of
um what actually happened
um to
cases across the piece broadly
um I mean I noticed one one note in
there that there's only five or ten
percent of them of the reports ever turn
into an actual enforcement case
um but rather more analysis along those
lines I think you know did was that
discussed and could we have some
thank you the chief planning officer I I
think I'm probably closer to the uh the
question of whether the matter of the
Drone got to I believe that uh the
question of personal privacy and data
protection became uh very difficult to
resolve as this discussion was being uh
taken forward within a project that
looked at this so as far as I'm aware uh
that that was sitting with a project
being led in IIT but it hasn't actually
reached a conclusion whereby it's
actually feasible or necessarily an
appropriate course of action to follow
as regards data
um in relation to the work of the joint
um The Joint member task and finish
group
um we didn't have uh reports around the
volume of cases which I believe is what
the council was asking about
um and we provided General statistics to
them across the workload that was coming
in across both councils so I don't know
if that answers uh Council Matheson's
question properly
yeah just just briefly
um yeah on the Drone I mean um
great was a couple of years ago and we
haven't quite got there yet
um but I think what what I'm
you know asking
when you were right so so there was some
this there was a report provided to the
working party
um did the working party consider what
additional reports might be welcome
we've obviously had one from various
courses about outstanding cases I just
was thinking more in terms of sort of
looking at a year and saying well that
five or ten percent
um you know they were this sort that
sort and the other sort
um and and they were
quarter of them were resolved with
applications and a quarter of them were
were considered not expedient whatever
though that sort of analysis was that
thought about
thank you
um so the working group focused on the
words in the policy uh as it's as its
primary focus rather than the work of
the team and the caseload and so to that
extent I mean there is no shortage of
data around cases and the the shape of
the work as it were I think the The
Joint member working group struggled to
wrestle the language used in planning
enforcement into a format that consensus
could be agreed around I don't think the
the the group got to the point of
actually looking at individual case
types how they were handled and what
matters were particularly relevant there
so it was very much a a discussion
around a plan which describes how the
Service as a whole work rather than the
specifics of particular types of
Investigation although as you'll
probably realize members had individual
experiences to bring to the group
thank you councilor Davies
thank you chair
um I hope I've got my page number right
on page 231 there's a a wonderful
annotated flowchart which has got lots
of references to the person reporting
the
the subject what I would like to ask is
have you considered adding another box
which which relates to court action
because it seems to stop at um
enforcement stroke other notice
Chief planning officer thank you through
you chair
um yes there are potential courses of
action off of this workflow into
enforcement notices prosecution and a
selection of other potential courses of
action that may follow so yes we have
considered them we haven't mapped them
out because they are a small number of
cases I think
um in 2022 we served 20 notices first
into 19 we served about 10 so Council so
the volume of work has gone up and it is
a small portion of the total so as a
measure of context I think in 2022 we'd
received 400 or approximately 400
investigation reports we served 20
notices and those may have been cases
that predated 2022 but as a as a general
amount of work for the purposes of the
uh the policy the plan we considered
that the most useful thing to do was map
out the bulk of the work which is what
you see in the workflow a bit in a
simplified format and the question of
how individual cases might route to
prosecution or to an appeal and a
timetable were probably less useful to
map out for the purposes of redrafting
the plan
thank you councilor Passmore thanks very
much Jim just a quick one with all the
housing growth and business growth
there's been over the last well say 20
years is there enough capacity within
the team to implement the new policy and
enough resilience
I wouldn't want to put people under more
pressure within the team and have you
taken that into account with your
forward plans of course thank you
director Planning and Building control
thank you
it's for you Jeff
um it's a it's a it's a subject that is
under constant
investigation and and seeking to
understand the capacity of the team
um there have been challenges with
recruitment as a recent real-time
planning Institute report which
describes the challenges across
enforcement nationally
particularly relating to skills and
experience available
the sector and it's something that we
continue to look at we have tended to
take a grow your own approach to the use
of resource and we are fully staffed
within the team we need to reflect on
that when it's been fully staffed for a
period of time to see how that relates
and also how we're able to bring people
on professionally to be able to progress
prosecutions we're we're confident that
um
registration has satisfactorily
supported officer asks for use of
resource and those kind of things we
will continue to monitor it as the kind
of fully resource team
progresses and develops and and brings
the new plan into effect
thank you councilor Pratt
but many of the planning enforcements
cases
probably
less kind of satisfactorily
um
the outcome is less satisfactory
received and it kind of comes back again
to
um what council Fleming was saying
really is the problem with a lot of
these a lot of these issues are
ephemeral issues
um dust being washed away by the rain
for example noise smells
um
maybe it wasn't directly planning
related actually but in one case career
code or creosote being used on a fence
close to a Waterway and these things are
very very difficult to prove
[Music]
I was thinking you know with regard John
John sort of took my question really I
hadn't realized that there was going to
be a drone
um or you were thinking about
implementing the use of a drone but to
get around to get around the gdpr issue
uh what we really need is just some sort
of form of live monitoring really if a
complaint comes in we should be able to
perform some sort of live monitoring
even if it's just
um a sensor that can pick up noise or um
particulates dust or even like a light
sensor that's been calibrated to do that
kind of job which would then be able to
to feedback
um
information on some sort of impact I was
just wondering if if another approach
is being considered uh alternatively to
drones the other sort of real uh the
thing that seems to to um
you know upset people within my ward is
when um hedgerows and trees are damaged
as well
um or perhaps a Hedgerow has been
promised and the trees are not planted
in a timely Fashion For That season or
the ones that are planted die and are
not replaced and it takes long it takes
years to to resolve so I was just
wondering really whether what we also
need is the local policy that gives our
planning Enforcement Officers some teeth
really to resolve those particular
issues
thank you
does anyone wish to comment
we through you chair offices will
continue to investigate the use of
Technology with things like sensors or
cameras or other things like that you
may still encounter privacy related
but we will continue to explore all
possible options that we've got and if
we can use technology to save office of
time then absolutely that'll be
something that we bring in
thank you councilor War boys
I think
the questions I got are actually sort of
almost
um all been answered but I think I just
would like to do so
if I may
um one is um about the ongoing
management of the the workload
workloaders as sort of appeared in the
conversation several times and
I have had some very
positive dialogues with planning
officers and
relatively successful outcomes I mean
the residents weren't completely
satisfied but on the other hand the
situation has been clearly and uh well
explained but these are very time
consuming
um
passages of work so I think there's a
management to the workload of offices is
really very important as well as their
training
um I think councilor Fleming was
implying what I think what I summed up
as a sort of impact of development
beyond the immediate neighborhood
I think there is a need perhaps in
planning documents
um to look at what does happen when
developments take place
um Nick Suffolk has got quite as
a a confining network of Roads so often
a development can take place in one
part of mid-suffer
but the impact of lorries and traffic is
only felt three or four miles away
um and I think that should perhaps be
looked at Within
planning application perhaps in more
forensic detail the impact of that
beyond the immediate area if that's
councilor War boys I will need to see a
question mark in this at some point yeah
so that is that is one question if you
like whether that's practical to put
that within the planning application the
impact beyond the immediate neighborhood
of traffic particularly traffic
movements
um and finally it's um about the unknown
unknowns and the knowns No No's
um I've had a very positive dialogue
about specific cases where I've been
very much a part of it but um but I know
there are
instances that things appear within my
ward that I haven't known about at all
but have already been to planning
control so I think
I would like to see if it's possible to
actually that sort of updates on what
happens within award members actual Ward
on a regular basis if that's practical
and that is probably adding to the
workload
I'll return to questions now with
councilor Manson
thank you now now I am I'd just like to
build on some of the ideas that have
already been mentioned by uh some of my
fellow councilors about the um how we're
going to update counselors now I I
personally would welcome some sort of
online
thing web page bit of software where I
could tap in and self-help a bit like
the planning portal has there any been
any consideration of having an
enforcement sort of planning portal
where I as a ward member could tap in
type in the name of my ward and come up
with a list of all the Enforcement cases
in the ward and what stage they're at so
that's my first question my second
question is
related to the outcome now we have a
couple of lovely graphs bar graphs in
our papers about the number of cases and
what type of case they are and we do get
our regular
um enforcement case update thing in an
email which which we can look at and it
just says resolved
um what I'd like to say some sort of
breakdown of what is the percentage of
cases that are reported
that are dismissed found to be no breach
or whatever the other outcomes are I
think that would be quite useful uh and
my third question is we all know of
several repeat offenders on enforcement
and is there anything in the plan policy
or whatever you want to call it that is
going to help us deal with those repeat
offenders thank you
Chief planning officer first firstly in
relation through firstly in relation to
the question of information for
counselors we haven't looked to invest
in a in a portal circumstance four
members we had considered whether or not
we could create and allow member access
to uniform software that raises various
other issues which
um actually means that's probably not
workable so for the time being we are
looking at the information that we share
through emails and through conversation
with members and you obviously have the
the general summary of uh information
provided to members in relation to uh
the question of cases and providing
information around case closures it's
not so much I would have said the
question of a policy a plan as we have
today that's a question of detail and I
think certainly there is discussion to
be had about the extent of information
that members get around cases that are
resolved
uh and we would hope that that becomes a
more
uh a more natural conversation over time
so it does not become a burden to
officers to uh write lengthy reports
upon but for each and every case that is
closed there is an expediency report
um these are written by Enforcement
Officers familiar with enforcement
language they are not necessarily
written for a purpose of sharing with
counselors uh albeit that one would hope
that they are accessible and uh can be
explained so I think there are there's
every opportunity to do this and I think
this is something that uh between the
director and I we will pursue because we
do wish to upgrade the quality of
information that members
have so that there is a a
straightforward conversation about the
nature of breaches accepting there may
be times then that we cannot necessarily
pursue a a an enforcement report
um and that's something that maybe of
dissatisfaction to the person who
reported it
thank you councilor wellum meet
offenders
I'm sorry
um would you like to come back my third
question was about repeat offenders I
apologize please
my my apologies through you repeat
appenders is an issue that the
government currently has on its
consultation in relation to various
things including on fees so um there is
definitely interest nationally about
dealing with this I think if you read
any uh any um Barrister's blog on these
sorts of things you'll find it becomes a
very very complicated matter of judgment
once you start taking into account past
Behavior bearing in mind that Planning
Commission runs with the land this
becomes a fairly complicated picture
very quickly and bearing in mind that a
planning Authority is expected to follow
its plan and judge things impartially
considering the merits of things rather
than individual circumstances uh I think
there are there is a they're all
ingredients for Mischief
um in relation to uh decisions or
actions which take account of past bad
behavior one encounters all sorts of
people who are misguided in their
judgments as many as you find people who
clearly have a will to do something that
is uh underhand uh judging between them
is a very difficult thing without
accurate information I think it's
something I I it would be very difficult
to write into a policy which would
actually be useful
thank you councilor wellum
thank you chair
when 275 homes say are built in open
Countryside outside of Village
there will be harm
this harm we are advised in planning
committees can be mitigated by the
property of hundreds of cheese
this is covered by our planning
condition the trees are planted and many
Die the parish council reports an
alleged breach
where in the priority listing would
investigating
this sort of breach form I asked this
question because often if the trees are
not replaced in a timely fashion within
a special specified period they will
never be replaced
there is significant harm if the trees
are not replaced but are there
sufficient resources to carry out a full
investigation of this this sort of
alleged breach and ensure that the
planting schemes are maintained in line
with the planning conditions
thank you Chad
thank you
Chief planning officer
through your chair the um prioritization
strategy describes the situation in
relation relation to breaches of
planning conditions which result In
Harm's General amenity and I would think
that the situation where you do not have
the Landscaping scheme expected being
secured for the long term through the
life of a condition which is uh by by
standard terminology five years then you
would certainly be opening an
investigation and viewing the matter on
site so that in terms of scoring under
prioritization you would have an
investigation to pursue then in terms of
that question of harm the second part of
the prioritization looks at the extent
of harm that will be caused in general
terms and I'm confident that there is
sufficient in this to Warrant further
action in relation to a breach
conditions such as you might find and
typically the result resolution to a
matter such as that would be a breach of
condition notice in order to ensure that
planting is undertaken to secure the
remeeding remedying of the defect that
you describe so in terms of
prioritization I think that the matter
would get looked into there are reasons
there it would score sufficient to be
investigated and then in terms of harm
subject obviously to the location and
the nature of the issue and the number
of trees that
were dying or had not successfully taken
then clearly one would look at probably
scoring the matter in terms of causing
harm that warrants further action
thank you very much I also asked if if
there are sufficient resources to carry
out these sorts of Investigation that's
my concern that that there are a number
of these sorts of instances they are I
would suggest they're probably fairly
time consuming uh and it may well be not
just one visit it may be visits your
annual visits throughout that five-year
maintenance period
um and if they're not carried out we end
up with no trees at the end of the five
years so the big question is
do we have the resources to do that
thank you
director Planning and Building control
through you chair I think it's a similar
answer to the the one provided to
councilor Passmore which is that we
believe that we have sufficient resource
if
the situation that you're describing
happens over and over and over and over
and over again in multiple different
places that will provide a challenge for
resourcing but we will have to keep a
close eye on workloads of Staff ensure
that we're managing those effectively
and come to counselors if there's a
requirement for additional resources in
order to meet that but we would hope
that the efficiencies that we're putting
in place
provide more scope and opportunity for
officers to to address those kind of
matters that were described
thank you very much after this item I'm
going to give everyone a comfort break
because we've been going for longer than
one and a half hours now but I will say
for the um questions please be as
concise
and as brief as possible and and is
direct but um thank you the good
questions counselor eburn
very much chair um
I'm in the
um plan it's been noted earlier and just
now that that the comment that we're
fully staffed within the team my
question is um you know while we fully
support the efforts of the enforcement
that the enforcement team take
during this process within this plan
were alternative ways of working
um looked at especially with the visits
to other councils and in order to kind
of just look at something completely
different to make this plan as effective
as possible thank you
thank you
thank you director the Planning and
Building control and yes a range of
different approaches have been
considered and looked at and I'm more
than happy to discuss and talk through
pros and cons and different things that
were explored and outside Limited
thank you councilor geek
after listening to
OLS I do hesitate hesitate to ask this
very inconsequential one but on page 216
about the powers that the council has
should it actually have that question is
this the right term please
I wonder if you might read the question
out sure it's just for clarity to save
everyone looking through their pages
Dean it says we have various powers to
remedy the breach we can do this by
requiring changes are made and it
explains that the removal of the
unauthorized development is this the
right term please that works the
unauthorized development should
immediately it sounds like a note that's
been put in
is it or I mean I'm conscious that I it
seems trivial but I don't want to vote
for something that that has got a
sentence in that shouldn't be there just
in case no thank you very much it's a
good question I'll put that to the
director of Planning and Building
control
that's one of the consequential changes
that would be covered under
recommendation the second recommendation
that allow me to make minor amendments
and remove certain things that may have
stayed in there that may have been
internal access to offices
thank you very much councilor Carter
thank you um
we've heard before of the term
feasibility used
and I had just wondered would it be more
or less feasible investing investing in
a live portal and a thesaurus in
layman's terms to update counselors or
and Say mischievous interests should
counselors be encouraged to actively
engage in hounding and phoning and
emailing the team asking for updates I
just wonder which would be more feasible
Chief planning officer thank you
through you chairman I mean I'd hope
that it becomes a natural conversation
over the course of time um as as the
Director said we have a full team now
they do not have a full Suite of skills
or experience in the profession and
therefore they are learning their craft
from my point of view they're taking the
right steps in being more Community give
um with counselors than many Enforcement
Officers I think encountered in the past
I don't think this should be about
councilors having to seek information
from uh officers of the team by pursuing
it I think it should be a natural
conversation whereby that that
conversation happens readily and or
straightforwardly on a regular basis uh
how we do that I think is is a matter
which doesn't necessarily rest in terms
of an enforcement plan but is a matter
of operational day-to-day good good
relations with councilors so that they
have the information necessary to go to
meetings and deal with their community
and in turn so that officers have any
local knowledge or local color that
helps us understand the nature of
individuals or the nature of sites that
are of particular interest so from our
perspective we would encourage
conversation we are in active discussion
about out how to do that as we go into a
future administration because clearly we
are encouraging officers to engage in
dialogue in a more active way and we
will need to revise the member training
that we provide to counselors about
planning enforcement
thank you very much I'd like to move to
debate now would anyone like to
counselor Whitehead to start the debate
oh sorry one last question from
councilor Whitehead and then we'll move
to debate thank you um
in my 12 years experience as a ward
member
um the emergency enforcement issues that
you know come to my attention
brought through Parish Council or
attending Clarity council meeting so
either a parish councilor or someone
attending a parish council meeting I
will bring it firstly attention of the
parish council who then um tend to
report him I certainly encourage more
recently the reporting via the parish
Clark said that they can be kept updated
now I see it talks in the
um policy related to keep you reasonably
updated from time to time but it's not
practical reasonable to provide a
running commentary on the investigation
which I certainly understand that
Hampshire Council meetings tend to be
either every two weeks sorry every two
months or every three months and that
clerk would tend to want to follow up on
that because once it's on the agenda and
in the minutes it then becomes a matter
of rising or you know an issue
unresolved so for example
um one of my parishes
um you know the 5th of September
asked do you have an update 6th of
September investigate investigation
reviews pending decision on next action
and then six sixth of December could
contribute for an update and
um the response there was a master of
brief of the case officer this is a team
leader I will update you as soon as I
have that and that was in December
um the um 16th of March still chasing
for another day coming I'm pleased to
hear that all participally Staffing that
this person who went for a site visit
has actually returned because I was
concerned about that but the reason they
do this is because the the clerks are
asking for this update not for running
commentary but because it comes up time
and time again in the meeting and if
it's not if they don't have an update
for this meeting it'll then be on the
agenda for the June meeting before you
know it it'll be saying it's a year has
gone by
but certainly when it comes to a parish
meeting and the clerk just reports they
haven't had an update all eyes then
turned to the award member uh you know
so this is your Council what you're
doing about it so I just a question the
question I would ask to officers is
please understand that for Parish clerks
in particular it's not necessarily
running commentary it's just an update
for for reasons of being on the agenda
thank you
planning officer
through your chair
um the the phrase in this plan is
um
is directed at the public in general so
one must give a piece of advice that is
good for all I think in terms of
important enforcement issues for parish
councils and sometimes they note and
sometimes they are particularly
interested in them I think that becomes
a question of how well and how
effectively we have individual
conversations around particular problem
cases and problem sites and and that's
something I think doesn't necessarily
um uh run in quite the same way as not
providing a running commentary I think
the message to the public is that we
cannot expect to provide updates and
some members of the public do expect
updates at every last um the hat and
probably bring members with their
concerns and their
who's around what they perceive as in
action from our perspective though we
may well be seeking legal advice we may
be pursuing action action around that
and we may wish to say very little about
that to the general public and say for
the purposes of a plan which is what
this is to say the council's position on
these investigations I think it's fair
enough that we provide the generic
statement that we have certainly in
relation to individual members I think
officers can be candid around the
position and understand that that can be
shared with parish councils as a matter
that
attained but clearly somewhere between
that and
providing full transparency over every
last step is a question of resources and
practicality and certainly
our other position is that in relation
to those who are under investigation
we would not necessarily wish to tell
them everything about our investigation
of that as that proceeds because they
may well be have innocently done what
they've done they may well on the other
hand wish to manipulate the situation
for their own advantage and so we must
be guarded and somewhat careful in how
we release information
so that the public have a picture that
we are taking active and that they have
confidence and that we are doing
something but do not necessarily have
the detail of that such that somebody
who is in breach can manipulate their
situation
thank you and councilor Carter and then
councilor Fielder no one cancel the
fields to be the last question please
I'm sorry counselor Carter please ask
your question field will be first for
debate thank you I was trying to come
back to my previous question is I fully
would welcome if we could have it in
conversation run conversation if we
weren't in this predicted situation
where our offices are outside of our
Awards if we weren't representing rural
communities being outside here many of
us have to train and get a train into
here or taxi we might not be able to get
here to talk to the officers
many of us will be having work outside
of these hours where outside the hours
where the offices may work so we may not
be able to catch each other in
communication
to make it easier for everyone to if you
had a live portal where you could see in
black and white and possibly then have
maybe book in a time for a team's course
something like that that fits in with
everyone else's lives but unfortunately
we we don't circulate in the same areas
we aren't able to always see each other
all the time and the times we do get in
it may not be out of the time especially
having conversation we need to so these
are important things that we need at our
fingertips at times that we can access
and not have to rely on a conversation
which we may not be able to see eye to
eye on
so this is something that's
would be best for members and probably
be less for some office as well to be
able to have it have his best engagement
and have a best working practice so
that's all I wanted to say thank you
thank you
um so councilor field
debate
a brief one perhaps chair
just really to point out that obviously
a new policy a revision taken
account recent experience is valuable
and one wouldn't want to stop it going
forward
but I think Council Whitehead's question
pointed out to me one of the absolutely
critical issues
which is that these things take forever
to resolve maybe because it's a
difficult subject the law does not move
rapidly
also my daughter-in-law always tells me
um
but local populations don't quite see
the justice of that
I have a fear that our new policy is is
a framework
I would like it to be a framework to get
planning enforcement done one feels it
may well be a framework just to explain
why things take forever to happen
I certainly have communities floating
for instance have issues that have been
going on for 17 years without revision
that's
probably as long as I've been a
counselor
so I would really say it's welcome that
we have a new policy we need to move
forward
we really do need to ensure that this
area has the resources to get things
done as rapidly
as legal process will allow
because the population
doesn't tolerate the delay and that
impacts on all our reputations
whichever then whether it's your
Administration or perhaps a different
one in the future whoever it is it
impacts upon us
people see these they're problems that
they're right up against
people are tolerating activities
blue leaves Park in great blakenham at
the moment see those problems they may
actually not be legally incorrect but
they see the problem and that impacts on
their belief in our
in our competence or lack of it so I
welcome the new policy but uh have
severe reservations about whether it
will be a solution to our problems
could I just see who wants to take part
in this debate because I'm aware that
we're getting up to two hours which is
pretty inhumane for a for a council
meeting and I think I might have to give
everyone a comfort break at this point
shall I say if does anybody want to put
their hands to for a comfort break and
one person will trigger that so um the
next question is does anyone need longer
than five minutes for that Comfort break
please pop your hand any hand will
trigger it to be 10 minutes
sorry
so what I'll do is if everyone can try
and do five minutes and then I will not
start the meeting till councilor Carter
returns
well there's still people want to talk
in the debate are they can I see Hands
of people that want to speak in this
debate
I think to be honest um
I do I'm I I think we need to break now
because um I don't think it's fair on
people that's a it's a long time without
a comfort break see
I wonder
um because I came in part way through
the meeting whether I should vote on the
item before me I just want to know to
Clarity on that
um I have read the document
for clarification you're absolutely fine
to vote on this um councilor Guthrie and
and thank you for making your way here I
know you've come a very long way today
so um thank you
so um we'll do um five minutes plus
thank you all we're back live now and
we're in the um debate
of um of this paper the first person to
go and debate is counselor mantle
uh thank you chair I I am I welcome this
this revised plan I'm sure all of us as
Ward members are regularly contacted by
residents about uh planning enforcement
or perceived planning uh breaches and it
can be a very emotive uh topic uh with
with some residents and I fully
appreciate that some of the information
is likely to be of a sensitive nature
um and I do think that this document
certainly helps us as Ward members uh
try to explain to those emotive rather
emotional residents
um and try to manage expectations which
is something that the chief planning
officer talks to me about managing
expectations of our residents and I
think it does help us I'm not convinced
it will help them without
um that they'll still want to have a run
and a rave us about Enforcement cases
um but I do I do think I would really
hope that
um the team take away the fact that that
we have suggested having some sort of
portal where we can we as members can
access a list of Enforcement cases in
our Awards
just to sort of touch base with them we
don't we don't want to be phoning
emailing having a teams chat with all of
the Enforcement Officers about every
little case in our Ward but what would
be really handy would be to be able to
access a list of those cases where we
can just touch base with them see which
ones we need to have a chat with the
officers about and which ones we don't
so I would like
a request for that to be looked at
whether we can have some sort of portal
where we can do that because I think
that would save us and the officers an
awful lot of time because they won't
have to be continually sending off
emails
um to us and vice versa we can we can
have a bit of self-help here and let's
try and not put all the burden on the
officer telling us what's going on and
we can ask about it but I do welcome
some sort of plan and I also very much
welcome the fact this is going to be
reviewed in 12 months so that we can see
if it is working and hopefully if if any
changes are needed they can be some
minor changes which can be incorporated
into the plan as it moves forward I
think it's a bit of a learning
experience learning curve and I must
admit I've found that the fact that
enforcement is only a discretionary
power of the district council bizarre
because it's one of the you know what it
almost what is the point of putting all
those conditions on a planning
application if we can't enforce it and
that's what the public think they see
these planning
permissions be granted they see all the
conditions and then they sort of say
well this isn't happening and it's
really really difficult so this does
help us I will be voting for it and I
welcome the review in 12 months time
thank you
thank you councilman Matheson
um yeah just just a couple of brief
points on I I asked some questions about
reporting earlier and councilman
ask them again in a different way
um
the the professional leave for digital
Solutions a very valuable member of the
um Team I have to say
um I asked him for a particular report
and it was produced in about 20 minutes
and he said is that right and I said you
almost like little tweak and every every
month I now get a report of all the
outstanding planning applications in my
wall which is great and
um so I think that there's probably
other you know reporting solutions that
that he can organize without any great
work being done by the the the the
burdened teams that there are the the
other point what I wanted to say was the
question was asked by
somebody
um about the you know checking whether
you know the trees were dying that had
been required under permissions and I I
came across that question a very long
time ago when I was a parish counselor
and when I asked it turned out that the
council had got no
um had got no provision to to check that
but I think the with hindsight now I
don't think we would ever have the
resources to check that as a council
frankly and I think that the parishes
should understand
that they need to check that the the
those particular Landscaping conditions
are carried out and if and if the and
that they go and see if the plot trees
are dying and and I'm fearful that
that's going to be you know the case
this year unfortunately and there's
going to be an awful lot of Replacements
needed but I think we should actually
put that responsibility clearly
somewhere else because there's loads and
loads of enforcement work that needs to
be done thank you
thank you very much councilor geek
thank you chair
um I I think this plan seems exciting I
will be voting to adopt it but I'd like
to expand councilor Fleming's very good
point in the questions about
construction traffic in my ward we've
got construction of 300 homes getting
underway right next to a main
residential Road
um and of course as no house Builder
builds so many houses at once at the
price drops
these developers going to be in our
village noisily building for a decade
we've already had many complaints both
to the award councilors into the parish
council we've had so many that the Press
have noticed and I expect there are
similar long-term problems in many other
Wars I I would hope that these can be
addressed it's not just a trans well it
is a transitory problem but it's a
long-term transitory problem
and it needs to be addressed so that as
councilor Fleming said that the
community feels that the planning system
is on their side it's something we
really do need to to get hold of thank
you
thank you Council Passmore
um thank you very much chairman just
very quickly picking up on them John's
point about enforcement on landscaping
and trees this comes up at our planning
meeting committee meetings very often
and I think we would all regardless of
which side of this place um the chamber
that's the word I was looking for
um Iran it is really really important
we've done this now if we need to
improve the system and develop it then
you can bet your bottom dollar
um that's what we should all be doing
because why should people
large development or a small development
if that is a condition for decent sizes
I would always say locally sourced
native species not a silly little whip
about that big but a decent size one
what they call a Rolls-Royce landscaping
and plastic planting
situation we need to make sure it's
enforced and then I'm not as pessimistic
as you there John I do think the
officers do know that it comes up of
planning regularly and um I think we've
got to all put our shoulder behind the
wheel and make sure Jolly well happens
because
um it's important otherwise we end up in
distribute disrepute and I shall
certainly be supporting this
recommendation thank you
thank you very much
um I see no more hands for debate
councilor melon
yes I should be voting for this for this
plan
um it looks to be a step forward and
also welcome that it's going to be
reviewed in in 12 months time and just a
couple of comments that
counselors really are a kind of front
line of of enforcement because we're the
people who meet
The Villages at Parish councils we all
the sort of public facing but we have to
explain the decisions to the public so
we are part of this process
um councilor wat has absolutely spot on
in terms of you know
from meeting to meeting being able to
give people an update that is that is
necessary and he's lucky perhaps that he
doesn't have a
you know a parish council every month
well I do sometimes uh and US asking for
for a review or you know an update
um
the phrase that we see in the reports
enforcement not expedient is not
something you can
say to a parish council very easily they
want to know more they want to know why
what's gone and what's the story behind
that and so I think we do need more
member involvement in this process and I
think what would be helpful for me
um every Monday we get an email which
says uh you know these cases have been
opened
these cases have been closed but we have
no idea how many open cases there are in
our Awards so um councilor um
Mike's
um suggestion that that we get a list of
that and and some interaction about
these cases so that we know what is
happening about them and then just a
mention of long-term cases I think these
these um these cases which don't seem to
get Revolt resolved you know even in 15
years
that they have a real power to kind of
have an impact on on the reputation of
the council
um
and I know we have to be fair to to the
people who are complained about but we
also need to be fair to the people doing
the complaining and the people who
suffer the consequences around there so
that I think there's a balance that
needs to be struck which I'm not sure
we're always getting right it would be
great to clear up some of these
long-standing cases if we can and I'm
aware that we have now a full team of
Enforcement Officers but that's not the
only part of the process we also need
resource at the legal end of the process
to progress some of these things when
they get to the sharp end of
so we'll be voting for it but those just
a few comments as well thank you
thank you councilor Carter
oh thank you yes I will also be voting
for this
um in favor of this
um and again I'd like to pick up a point
about to be portal and be getting new
updates which would be very beneficial
to the councilors well I do pick up over
Point made about some of these should be
beneficial face-to-face engagement
so
it can make we're going to have a lot of
new councilors a lot of new faces and I
would welcome the opportunity for if we
if they could have a one-to-one day with
enforcement team to meet the whole team
not just not just a general get-together
we're having the end of a house called
actual
get together and a sit down an
explanation about what what's can be
what evidence is collected or planning
to get shown what is what is going into
it because there's been cases where
there's say
come out to playing there's been so yeah
lovely wildlife area grass Hedges of
anxiety which has been chopped down
destroyed ratified photos of it for one
day and then when the team comes to it
the next
but a photograph isn't counted as
evidence
so if we get the
Community is wondering well what would
count as evidence if it's a photograph
with a date and time isn't what is so it
would be helped with counselors it can
be shown what is evidence what how it is
collected and what was lawful it'll be a
bit more beneficial to the new
councilors coming in and be able to get
one to one but either way I'll be right
in their favorites
thank you very much councilor Stringer
yep very briefly chair thank you for the
time uh I was happy to be in Minnesota
Green today and I saw the outcome of a
of a truly brilliant enforcement case
where someone had built a home nowhere
near the plans that they'd submitted way
too far out the ground way too big and
this Council took it all the way legally
and they had to demolish that home
uh and they then came back with an
inappropriate plan that that building is
now on the market I suggest you go look
at it it's a very nice little building
and what's best about it it actually
fits in to the streetscape and it's
precisely what the parish council asked
the developer to do right at the very
start which then wasn't complied with
during the process and and thank you for
Midsouth like reinforcing that and
forcing that uh developer to demolish
that home because what we've now got is
a is a house in that streets that we're
actually proud of and it instilled
Confidence from that Parish Council in
the system
and cause more to engage in it which is
a good thing can I make one uh One Plea
though is that
if enforcement is not complied with and
we do end up having to take legal action
does the legal service that we use have
enough resource to make sure they can
cope with the amount of cases thank you
debate so I'd like to take this now to
the vote please
um I'd like to now ask the corporate
manager governance and Civic office to
conduct the electronic votes please
thank you chair that vote is now ready
for councilors to cast their vote
councilor Guthrie can I take your vote
yes Paul thank you
and cancer Carter
thank you
chair that is 30 votes for thank you
that's unanimous and thank you everyone
that was involved in that I think
there's some really useful
I'd like to move on to the um next item
which is item 12
mc2245 councilors parental leave policy
and I'd like to invite councilor Morley
to introduce this item and to move the
recommendation please
thank you chair
um this
um
policy has been drafted by our local
government Association
it is a
a template
policy that we are looking to adopt
across the whole of Suffolk actually
though I believe also that many
councilors not just in Suffolk are also
looking to adopt it so
um
currently there is no legal entitlement
for any counselor to take a
parental leave of any kind and this
seeks to address that lack
so I'm happy to propose it and we'll
call for a second thank you
councilor Richardson
reserve my right to speak
thank you very much we'll now move to
questions councilor Otten
slightly surprised that the obviously
written by the LGA is very much written
in what I would
say is a traditional family for by a a
traditional family
for example a paragraph two two can I
ask it says counselors giving birth
now there may well be many counselors
who are not in that traditional family
unit the child may be for example a
surrogate child
it then goes on to mention adoptive
children which I'm very pleased about
but there is no mention of fostering
and the other question I have is further
down on the time if a parent
has a miscarriage and it states 25 weeks
and I'd like to know where that figure
has come from I think it's somewhat
arbitrary and I would hope that there
would be
certainly more flexibility there but I
just feel
chairman the whole paper is written
still under the premise of a traditional
family unit of a for one at one point it
actually says paternal leave it may not
be if you use the word correctly a a
father
so I really feel that we should consider
whether this the way that this paper is
written is actually of the 21st century
thank you
thank you and I'll ask the corporate
manager governance and Civic office
through a clarification of this and a
bit of the background please
thank you chair
um so it
the the different types of partnership
that you are are covered because it does
cover the it says the birth of their
children if they are the biological
father or care of the child is nominated
by the partner or spouse so that he's
covered that any type of relationship
should be covered by this
um and the 25 weeks is the normal
um well it's it's the week where they
say that the birth is mostly viable but
obviously if there was circumstances
that happened before that where the
birth was viable and the baby was born
um you know premature that time that
would still be taken into account and
there is that opportunity because it is
always available for discussion so
there's a flexibility in there that
which should cater for any any
eventuality
but I would like to to put it forward to
the leader of the council and the chief
executive that we do go back to the LGA
I'm probably going into debate here
sorry German to say that we feel that
they need to rewrite this in a much more
up-to-date exclusive manner thank you
okay thank you councilor mantle
thank you chair
um maybe I am completely got the wrong
stick but I was under the impression
that the only legal obligation that I
had as a counselor was to turn up to a
council meeting every six months
I'm not an employee
but and I get an allowance
whilst I don't have a problem with a a
parental leave policy uh I'm not
actually being paid for the hours that
I'm doing anyway
um and and I I I feel a bit like what's
the point of the policy if the one thing
I'm legally obligated to do which is
turn up to a council meeting every six
months isn't covered so should I be
somebody who was having some parental
leave and
um I hadn't attended a meeting for six
months and it was in the middle of a
parental leave thing I would have the
added stress of at having to ask for
that leave that to be extended so that I
didn't have to turn up to the council
meeting at my six-month thing so is
there any way that can be uh com that
can we can we take that bit out I mean
if you're going to have a leave policy
um how come the one thing we're legally
obligated to do isn't included
thank you and now the corporate manager
governance and Civic office and
clarification yeah so thank you chair so
councils do have the six-month
obligation obligan rule but allows you
six months
um
so and then the expiry date after that
so that you could have your six months
and then have another six months on on
the top of that but it is covered so you
still have a legal requirement to do the
six months but you'd have dispensation
not to attend that meeting in that time
thank you a question from councilor geek
thank you chair this this is um about uh
this is on page 234 the um 4.5 key
points from the policy include any
counselor who is the designated carer
will be entitled to six month sleeve dot
um who who exactly is a designated carer
and
who's in who designates them as such
um
corporate manager governance and Civic
office
so thank you chair so the designated
care is actually the the person
um he's a
partnership without getting into to
who's what but who is designated as
either the the the the person who's
looking after the child or the person
who's
um may wish to take the paternity side
of things but yeah the designated carer
is
um the person who's looking after the
baby
how's the geek would you like to come
back could I
[Music]
yeah the after the amount of maternity
leave I've had perhaps um but uh
does that mean that one person has to be
designated as a primary carer and the
other person is a secondary care and is
that done by the parents
right so you cannot have a wholly shared
parental leave even though we are now in
the in the era of shared parental leave
so yes chair there is provision for that
um and if if there is a share if you
wish to use a shared leave there's
provision for you to share those um 52
weeks or 26 weeks each
don't come back again thank you very
much is it possible then to say a
designated
but I think all of this is is is
following the same principle that that
it looks great but the language is a bit
is it's moving so fast this area that we
need to keep up
um point take and and I'm happy to amend
that wording
um without having to go through an
amendment that's just a what you know
any further questions
um so we'll take it for him to debate
please
um would anyone like to open debate
no well personally I welcome this
um wholeheartedly
um
I as you'll know I have got two young
children
um my first child was born in lockdown
for this very start of lockdown and um I
was actually talking to the grants team
in the hospital room when um when I
mentioned to the grants officer the um I
that's where I was I was in the labor
Ward and he immediately said don't worry
I'll handle this so um
I I do absolutely welcome this there's
um I think this does cover
with that designated care the amendment
I'm happy with
um but I think this does cover diff the
different ways things uh being done
nowadays A lot of my um
paternal parent friends are
taking doing the child care in the early
days now and it's it's you know this is
something that's got to be very flexible
but I absolutely um welcome this I think
if um if this was about when I had my
children I probably would have still
come to every meeting I could because I
just it if I you know if I can I will
attend the meetings but it does take
away the feeling that you're not doing
your job properly if you don't and I
think that's um that's a really
important part of this because we need
we need to have these things in place
because we see younger councils we we
could definitely see some younger
counselors in the next intake
um
counselor Pratt is also
um they're very proud and father of a
young child I think um I think politics
is changing at the local level whereas
we we do want to welcoming as possible
to everyone that wants to do it and that
you know that's fantastic so really
wholeheartedly support this I will be
voting for it
um thank you very much
councilor Carter sorry I forgot you when
I mentioned um children
um yes before we do about this
I do support in theory but reading it
in plain English black and white if I'm
struggling to understand if it's not
really made out to be as
open as it could be is not to have to
ask these questions this document is
going to be as it is and somebody
reading it first is going to lead to
these same questions again you doesn't
sit feel
open to me it doesn't feel it it makes
me feel question say it's be
with with children has a child and the
grandparent ends up with a child it does
happen the grandparents end up raising a
child
but it just seems
a bit of a degree of confusion and it
doesn't say specifically say that you
could miss be six months beforehand and
then not have to seek the situation it
doesn't say that
um because it could be a case where
somebody has medical issues with the
pregnancy have to miss six months and
then feel that they still have to seek
participlementation
and it's not always we love children we
love having to think it's not always the
happiest time but it can be lots of
mental health issues that come with it
with a childbirth such as
posting depression which again is not
going to be able to seek out it's going
to be very stressful
so it's not as open in a document as I'd
like to see
and that's why I'm very I fully support
the idea
but the document as it's written is very
difficult for me to vote for
so
the idea I'd love to vote for it I just
wish this document was as open and
inclusive and as Forward Thinking in
layman's terms as it could be to need
Doctor counselor or somebody picking us
off the Internet it's going to be as
confuses with questions raised here
that's my issue here I'm afraid
thank you very much Count's the past
more very quickly chairman I think we're
in danger of overthinking this we're
only talking about 34 people or all will
be councilors we've got the advice here
and I think let's vote for it let's put
this through and then if there's any
clarification needed I don't think this
Council has ever tried to exclude anyone
we've had people have had serious
accidents serious illnesses car
accidents and so on and we as a council
forget the politics have always
supported them whoever or wherever they
come from so I'm very very confident put
this policy and if we need to tweak it
and amend a few words that's fine but
please remember we're only talking about
elected councilors here we're not about
the wider population I know the officer
team will be happy to help and we would
all be very happy to help each other so
um let's go for it thank you
thank you very much and I think that's
the end of this um debate so I'd like to
um thank you all and um
turn to the corporate manager governance
and Civic office to conduct an
electronic vote please thank you chair
that is showing in blue for you to cast
Guthrie yes thank you for thank you
foreign
thank you that's 29 votes for and one
abstention so that's carried thank you
very much
so moving on to item 13
mc2246 special urgent decisions taken by
officers under delegated powers in
accordance with part two of The
Constitution and I'd like to invite the
chief executive to introduce this report
thank you thank you chairman as members
know we're obliged to report for noting
items where decisions have been made
outside of the meeting particularly with
a special urgency but also where calling
has been exempt in this particular case
that has happened and you can see the
detail within the report that the reason
for doing so is that this is an
externally funded government-funded
scheme which required spending by the
end of this month and therefore in order
to ensure that that was possible it was
essential that the decisions were made
outside of meetings in the usual way I
know Casa melon has kindly submitted two
questions in advance for me to look at
unfortunately I don't have the answers
here this evening as they only came in
this afternoon but happy to answer those
outside of the meeting thank you Jim
okay thank you could I have a proposer
for this report please councilor epignon
and a seconder
councilor Passmore I think you would
just in front say thank you very much
[Music]
um
so um this report is just for noting so
we won't have a vote on this um
but does anyone have any questions
counselor eburn
um thank you very much chair just just
given the issues we've had with um
electric car charging points such as at
Needham Lakes which is just appalling
situation that's been going on for
months and months
um can we have some reassurance about
how this company was chosen and
um in this instance to make sure that
the work that they will do will not
encounter the same problems that
occurred at Needham Lakes thank you very
much
chief executive yeah that was one of the
questions that councilman submitted in
advance can't provide that answered and
happy to do so outside of the meeting
councilor field
probably rather similar again I was just
going to ask you know obviously uh I
assume you've chosen this company as a
highly confident company
but it doesn't actually make that clear
at all it could be anyone
could be an expert in door three diving
through my nation so one would need to
know what was the basis which obviously
they're one of the sound basis but one
would like some reassurance thank you
chief executive again happy to answer
outside of the meeting the only thing I
would say is that the title is slightly
a clue that it's naughty not Nazi diving
in terms of Anglia car charging does
kind of imply what they do for a living
but but I take the point
thank you very much are there any
further questions
okay thank you very much we'll move on
to the next item and that is item 14
mc2247 paid policy statement 23 24.
um I'd like to invite the chief exec to
introduce this item and to move the
recommendations
thank you chairman so again as
counselors will be aware we're legally
obliged as set out within the reports to
adopt uh at pay pay policy statement on
an annual basis the report that you have
set up sets out that draft pay policy
statement as appendix a that appendix a
is extremely similar to the version that
you saw last year the only changes that
have been made are as a result of the
decisions that you made last year so
those are changes in relation to the job
titles of the directors and the deputy
chief executive and the ancillary pay
that goes with those posts so those are
the only changes that you will have seen
compared to the version that you saw
this time last year and there are no
proposals to make any further changes to
this document for the subsequent year
okay thank you very much could I have a
proposer please councilor Morley
the seconder councilor Richardson
happy to Second thank you
Jeff thank you very much
um we we have the head of HR here for
any questions on this would anyone like
to ask a question
no no questions
um would anyone like to start debate on
this item
no thank you very much
so um we'll go straight to the boat then
and I will now ask the corporate manager
governance and Civic office to conduct
the electronic vote please thank you
chair that is in progress for cancers to
cast their vote
cancer Godfrey
four don't thank you
I've fallen off the Wi-Fi
um so yeah I'll have to do my vote
manually and it's a form thank you
councilor Brewster
foreign
thank you that's 30 votes for so that's
unanimous so that's carried thank you
very much
um the next item item 15 has been
withdrawn
so um we'll go straight on to item 16.
which is counselor appointments are
there any changes in place
no no
okay thank you very much item seven
motions on notice
none received okay thank you very much
um the next meeting is um the annual
council meeting on Monday the 22nd of
May 2023 at 5 30 p.m
um I wish you all well and thank you
very much for attending this meeting
good night